[Music]
raise your hand if you love Disney
movies as much as we do it's no surprise
that Disney films go through a lot of
rewrites in order to get the stories
just right
we were totally astonished at some of
the alternate endings we found to our
favorite movies especially the last on
our list new here make sure to subscribe
to the things and click the like button
if you love Disney now check out 10
alternate endings to our favorite Disney
movies The Little Mermaid The Little
Mermaid is a story of fish meat boy fish
loves boy fish gets in a bunch of
trouble with a mean sea witch then fish
lives happily ever after Disney's
version of this classic tale had a
singing along with the fun musical
numbers and laughing at the sea
creatures sidekicks but as it turns out
the creators had a more brutal ending in
mind before changing it to what we know
in the film the creators shared the
storyboard of the original ending and
it's pretty epic this ending features a
final battle between Ursula and her eels
Arielle Prince Erik Sebastian and
flounder in this version Erik only has a
tiny little rowboat which snaps into
like a pencil and Ursula doesn't grow
into a huge sea monster but she does try
to squeeze and hold Erik underwater with
her tentacles Sebastian gets the Trident
- Erik just in the nick of time
and he Spears it into Ursula's chest the
storyboards alone are pretty scary it's
no wonder they went with the whole
driving the ship into Ursula's gut
ending instead both versions have a
happy ending Arielle became part of
Erik's world and Ursula was cursed down
into the fathoms below the Lion King The
Lion King is a warning to all of us
about what could happen when you don't
get along with your family it turns out
even lions have trouble getting along
with their brothers but scar takes this
sibling rivalry thing to a whole other
level in the theatrical film ending scar
tries to throw Simba off of a cliff the
same way he did Mufasa
but Simba gets the better of him and
forces him to confess to the pride that
he was responsible for mufasa's untimely
demise
since scar is cowardly he blames the
hyenas and says it was all their idea to
take over Pride Rock the hyenas don't
like that very much and scar is left to
deal with their wrath while Simba
returns as rightful king but the
creators played with the different
ending before that one in the alternate
ending scar actually succeeds in
throwing Simba off the rock Simba is
defeated but he survives he's there with
his mother as she wakes up scar is
laughing because he thinks he's won but
he is surrounded by flames his reign as
king is a short one because he becomes
consumed by the fire that engulfs Pride
Rock which ending do you prefer hyenas
or fire Beauty and the Beast in 2017
Disney came out with a live-action
version of its animated classic from the
early 90s they made a lot of updates to
the story which included adding three
new songs they also made some lyrical
changes to the songs Belle Gaston and be
our guest at Emma Watson's request they
gave Belle more of a backstory and made
her the inventor instead of her father
the film implied that Belle had invented
a washing machine so she could read
books while her clothes were being
washed watson also insisted that her
character wear boots instead of dainty
black flats and some cloths strung along
her belt instead of an apron the
creator's had a very different ending
plan for the live-action film but it
didn't do well with audiences in their
original ending the prince was supposed
to emerge shirtless from a bed of roses
the actor playing the prince talked
about it in an interview he said several
mothers pointed out that if he's without
a shirt during that moment he is
probably without the rest of his clothes
too they did not want their kids to see
that so they had to reshoot the ending
with a fully clothed Prince Toy Story 3
did you know that Toy Story 3 was set to
end in Taiwan the story we all know is
that Andy is 17 and going to college so
he decides to donate all of his old toys
to a daycare in the daycare they meet a
tyrannical teddy bear who forces the
toys to be prisoners of baby abuse the
toys escape and reunite with Andy who
decides to give them to a lovely child
the child promises to take good care of
the toys and they play together before
Andy goes off into the grown-up world
sweet right
that wasn't what Disney had in mind at
first Disney tried to steal the Toy
Story saga from Pixar and create a
radically different film they wanted the
story to be centered around Buzz
Lightyear having a malfunction according
to this alternative storyline all the
Buzz Lightyear dolls were recalled and
sent to Taiwan to be fixed then woody in
the gang journey to Taiwan to rescue
Buzz not only is this a repeat of the
theme in Toy Story 2 the story lacked
heart it was also missing the growing up
and moving on theme that was so powerful
in the final film so they ultimately
scrapped it and went for the daycare
plot paint goodness lilo and Stitch when
lilo and Stitch came out in theaters in
2002 the country was still recovering
from the attacks on the World Trade
Center from 2001 this was supposed to be
the feel-good movie audiences needed but
it had a major problem there was an
action sequence at the end of the film
that would have triggered a traumatized
nation they had to make a pretty big
change to the ending before they
released it originally lilo and Stitch
had an action-packed ending where Stitch
hijacked a commercial airplane to rescue
lilo stitch in his pals take over a 747
filled with scared passengers then they
go on a high-speed chase dipping through
and even clipping skyscrapers and coming
close to pedestrians on the ground it's
pretty triggering to watch obviously the
filmmakers couldn't show that ending
after what the country had just been
through on 9/11
so they rewrote it in the final released
version stitch takes over a red white
and blue spaceship and instead of flying
through the city the animators had it
take place over Hawaii's mountains and
volcano landscapes this made for a much
more pleasant movie going experience for
American audiences it was definitely the
right call Cinderella the old animated
Disney classic Cinderella is light and
fun with the singing mice and the
magical fairy godmother what's not to
love but the truth is Disney had to tone
down the darkness of the original Grimm
brother version in the
and there's a white dove instead of a
fairy godmother the Dove brings
Cinderella a dress and slippers so she
can go to the ball and just like the
film she loses a slipper for the prince
to find the prince goes through the
village looking for the foot to fit the
shoe pretty similar so far right well
here's where it gets a bit dicey the
stepmother actually convinces the first
stepsister to chop off her toes so that
she can fit in the shoe pouch anyway the
Prince notices the blood and goes back
on the hunt he meets the second
stepsister who's been talked into
cutting off her heel seriously what is
wrong with these people
finally the Prince sees Cinderella and
remembers that she is the one he fell in
love with at the ball at their wedding
white doves peck the eyes out of the
stepsisters as punishment for their
cruelty jeez wonder why Disney decided
to change it The Hunchback of Notre Dame
the Disney version of The Hunchback of
Notre Dame is actually adapted from a
novel written by Victor Hugo the novel
is pretty dark compared to the Disney
version in the movie Quasimodo the
super-strong Hunchback who is the
bellringer at Notre Dame saves the Gypsy
Esmeralda from the sinister Frollo then
Esmeralda hooks up with the gorgeous
soldier Phoebus even though Quasimodo
has a crush on her but the novel is way
more complicated in the book after as
Marella refuses fro those advances he
gets very angry and falsely accuses her
of a horrible crime he tries to have her
executed Quasimodo swings down from the
bell tower and saves her and brings her
back to the church where she is safe
under the sanctuary law eventually
Frollo overturns the law and barges into
the church to claim Esmerelda when she
refuses to be with him again he succeeds
in having her executed Quasimodo is so
angry he pushes Frollo off the bell
tower then the grief-stricken hunchback
goes and lays next to Esmerelda in her
grave and starves himself not so happily
ever after is it Disney really had their
work cut out for them to make this story
palatable for children snow white snow
white also started out as a Grimm
brothers fairy tale just like Cinderella
apparently in olden times these fairy
tales were designed to scare the bejesus
out of kids so that they would have a
good moral compass and not be greedy
mean little trolls it's clear that
Disney's intentions are to entertain
kids and keep them coming back for more
so they had to tone down the
fear-mongering from these stories quite
a bit there are a lot of similarities
between the original fairy tale and the
Disney movie the Evil Queen has a magic
mirror which tells her that Snow White
has taken her place as the fairest in
the land the Queen sets out to poison
and destroy snow white snow white eats
an apple and falls asleep until the
prince comes by and sees her beauty in
the Disney version true love's kiss
breaks the spell of the poison and Snow
White and the prince live happily ever
after but here's where the story really
takes a turn in the old version Snow
White and the prince invite the Evil
Queen to their wedding but it's a trap
when she gets there they slap on a pair
of burning hot iron shoes which force
her to dance until she passes out yikes
Moana we are living in a time where we
get to discover what a female heroine
looks like many films try to portray a
female protagonist as a masculine type
warrior who is just as capable as
kicking butt as any male counterpart but
Disney's Moana decided to go a different
way
however they had to go through a couple
of drafts to get there in the film Moana
employs the help of the demigod Maui to
restore the heart of taffy tea and stop
the destruction of the islands but they
have to go through the fire ichika first
in an older version of the script Moana
and Maui fought chica it was mainly Maui
that got the credit for defeating tikka
the creator said that ending didn't make
mulana the star of the third act and
they really wanted to get Maui out of
the way for that moment in the final
version Moana realizes that she doesn't
need Maui to restore the heart of taffy
tea she also realized that she and Takei
are similar and that they are both
searching for who they truly are she
uses her intuition as a young woman
rather than aggression and peacefully
reminds to cough who she is
the result is a beautiful story that is
unique to the Disney princess stories of
the past
frozen did you know that in
original version of frozen Elsa was a
villain at first
Anna and Elsa weren't sisters they
weren't royalty either Elsa was a
self-proclaimed snow queen who was
power-hungry and evil similar to the old
Hans Christian Andersen tale by now we
know how morbid those old fairy tale
stories are the ending was supposed to
have an epic battle where Elsa attacked
Anna and her friend with an army of snow
monsters
apparently Elsa became a villain because
she was super ticked off that a guy
dumped her and broke her heart so
everyone thought she had a frozen heart
that was prophesied to destroy the
kingdom but even in the old version
Hans is a jerk and turns out to be the
true unfeeling bad guy with a
metaphorical frozen heart they changed
the story because they felt the audience
would have no emotional connection to
Elsa plus they felt like that story has
been done like a thousand times already
so they went with the royal sister
storyline it's a good thing too because
now we have the magical songs let it go
it seems Disney always knows how to get
it right in the end and that's it for 10
alternative endings to Disney movies we
hope you enjoyed the video see you next
time
[Music]